My name is Redd Pepper.
I'm a voice-over artist.
In the UK, I've voiced hundreds of movie trailers.
Men in Black, saving the earth from the scum of the universe;...
...Blair Witch Project, Armageddon, Space Jam, Mr. Bean's Holiday.
So many I forget half of them, to be honest with you.
I started doing television adverts, animations, audiobooks.
I do a lot of video games as well,...
...and a lot of them are sound effects and ghouls in the background.
Mr. Bean.
When I first started doing movie trailers, it was fun.
"One Man, coming soon to a cinema near you."
Sometimes, I do romantic movies.
"In a sleepy town"...
Sometimes, I'm doing horror.
"Don't answer the door."
You got to use your voice.
You got to raise it sometimes...
...and you got to take it to the depths.
Very occasionally I get recognized, but generally no.
But the time I do get recognized,...
...phone goes off in the train, guaranteed...
Hello.
...and people look up from behind the newspapers.
The way I got into being a voice artist was kind of strange.
I used to drive trains on the London Underground.
One morning, I was making my announcements.
"All stations to Harrow.
Mind the doors."
A television executive was a passenger on my train.
He got off at the next stop, ran up to my cab,...
...we exchanged details and the rest is history.
I appreciate what I do.
I'm still meticulous about what I do.
I'm still proud of what I do.
I really don't look at it as a job.
I'm having fun.
It really is a cool job.
It's got to be up there with one of the coolest jobs on the planet, right?
You got it?
Cool.
I'm out of here.